Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Okay, flights on air Canada. How about Prague? Ooh, Paris. Those gardens. Gardens. Amsterdam. Tulip Festival. I see your festival and raise you a carnival in Venice. Or Bermuda has carnival. Oh colorful. You want colorful.
感谢您收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。好的，加拿大航空公司的航班。布拉格怎么样？哦，巴黎。那些花园。花园。阿姆斯特丹。郁金香节。我用你的节日，加码威尼斯狂欢节。或者百慕大也有狂欢节。哦，五彩缤纷。你想要五彩缤纷。
Thailand. Lantern Festival. Boom. Book it. Um how did we get to Thailand from Prague? Oh right Prague. Oh boy. Choose from a world of destinations if you can. Air Canada. nice travels. The figure of Edward the Confessor comes down to us faint, misty, frail. The medieval legend, carefully fostered by the Church, whose devoted servant he was, surpassed the man. The lights of Saxon England were going out, and in the gathering darkness a gentle grey-beard prophet foretold the end. When on his deathbed, Edward spoke of a time of evil that was coming upon the land, his inspired mutterings struck terror into the hearers. Only Archbishop Stigand, who had been Godwin Stalwart, remained unmoved, and whispered in Harald's ear that age and
泰国。灯节。砰。订了。呃，我们是怎么从布拉格到泰国的？哦，对，布拉格。天哪。如果可以的话，在世界的目的地中随意挑选。加拿大航空公司，祝您旅途愉快。忏悔者爱德华的形象传到我们这里时，显得模糊、朦胧而脆弱。被教会精心树立的中世纪传奇，超出了这个人的本身，而他曾是教会的忠实仆人。萨克森英格兰的灯火正在熄灭，在渐浓的夜色中，一位温和的白胡子先知预言了结局。当爱德华在临终前谈到将要降临这片土地的邪恶时代时，他受启示般的喃喃自语让听者感到恐惧。只有斯蒂甘德大主教，这位戈德温的坚强拥护者，依然无动于衷，并在哈拉尔德耳边低语说，年龄和
sickness had robbed the monarch of his wits. Thus, on January 5th, 1066, ended the line of the Saxon kings. So that was the audiobook of The History of the English-Speaking Peoples, So that was the audio book of the history of the English speaking peoples and that was read by none other than Sir Winston Churchill, Tom the top Britain of all time. And that book, interestingly, was published in 1956. But I read from a very reputable historian, that's you, that Churchill wrote those words, or I quote, reportedly wrote those words. Supposedly.
疾病剥夺了这位君主的理智。因此，在1066年1月5日，萨克森国王的血脉走到了尽头。这就是《英语国家史》的有声书，这就是温斯顿·丘吉尔爵士亲自朗读的《英语国家史》，他是英国有史以来最伟大的英国人。有趣的是，那本书出版于1956年。但我从一位非常权威的历史学家——也就是你——那里读到，丘吉尔写下了这些话，或者我引述一下，“据报道”写下了这些话。据推测。
In April 1940, when England's preparing to stand alone against Mr. Hitler and his Nazi thugs. Yes, and when Churchill, he wasn't yet prime minister, he was first Lord of the Admiralty. And so he was surrounded by maps of the English coastline. And of course, he was pondering the risks of divided leadership of antiquated defenses of threats of invasion from overseas. And so it's no wonder that he wrote about 1066 and the fall of Anglo-Saxon England, perhaps in tones of slight foreboding. Yeah, I mean, he's got one terrible foreign menace on his mind, the Normans, and another looming just on the horizon.
在1940年4月，当英格兰准备独自对抗希特勒先生和他的纳粹暴徒时。是的，当时丘吉尔还不是首相，他是海军第一大臣。因此，他被英格兰海岸线的地图所包围。当然，他在权衡分裂领导层、陈旧防御以及来自海外入侵威胁的风险。因此，他会写下1066年和盎格ルー萨克森（盎格鲁-萨克森）英格兰的陷落，并带着一丝不祥的预感，也就不足为奇了。是的，我的意思是，他脑海中有一个可怕的外国威胁，即诺曼人，另一个威胁正在地平线上隐现。
Yeah. Well, I mean, also, of course, his mind is on Norway. And as we will see the threat of invasion from Norway as well. And 1940, the year in which he is writing that in itself, of course, will become a fateful and famous year in British history and Churchill's role in that because he becomes prime minister the following month means that he doesn't really have much time during, you know, the defense of Britain and the blitz and so on to ponder the Norman conquest and the defence of Britain and the Blitz and so on, to ponder the Norman conquest.
是的。嗯，我的意思是，当然，他的心思也在挪威。正如我们将看到的，来自挪威的入侵威胁也是如此。1940年，他写下这些话的那一年本身，当然也成了英国历史上宿命而著名的一年，丘吉尔在其中的角色意味着，在英国保卫战和闪电战等期间，他其实没有多少时间去思考诺曼征服和英国的防卫以及闪电战等等，去思考诺曼征服。
And the events of that year are themselves now part of British history and 1940 is one of the most famous dates in British history. But I would say that even so, not 1940, not 1815, not 1805, not 1588, not 1415, all of which are years which show Britain or and or England in a very good light. Yeah. Defeating foreign enemies, smiting them. Smiting Germany, the French or sometimes the Spanish. Or the Germans.
那一年的事件现在本身也成为了英国历史的一部分，1940年是英国历史上最著名的日期之一。但我要说，即便如此，不是1940年，不是1815年，不是1805年，不是1588年，不是1415年，所有这些年份都将英国或/和英格兰置于非常光明的视角下。是的。击败外国敌人，痛击他们。痛击德国人、法国人或有时是西班牙人。或者德国人。
Yeah. A whole range of people getting defeated. A whole range of historical villains. And yet the weird thing is, is that none of those dates can compare for resonance or fame with 1066, a year which sees England invaded, defeated and conquered. And I don't know whether Arthur has yet reached the stage of studying it. He's done it. He's got exams on it next week on 1066. I mean, all the time we're talking about Harold Ardrada and William and Harold and all that stuff.
是的。形形色色的人被打败。形形色色的历史反派。然而奇怪的是，这些日期中没有一个能在共鸣或名气上与1066年相比，那一年见证了英格兰遭到入侵、击败和征服。我不知道亚瑟是否已经到了学习这个的阶段。他已经学过了。他下周有关于1066年的考试。我的意思是，我们一直在谈论哈拉尔德·哈德拉达、威廉、哈罗德以及所有这些事情。
Cause when, when my daughters went from primary school to secondary school, the first history that they did in secondary school was 1066. I mean, that's what that's, that was their introduction basically to, you know, the history of England. And it struck me at the time, I can't imagine French or American students being introduced to their country's history with a record of their country being defeated, occupied and humiliated. It speaks to our extraordinary self-confidence and self-assurances as people that we enjoy
因为当我的女儿们从小学升入中学时，他们在中学学习的第一段历史就是1066年。我的意思是，这就是他们的基本入门，让他们接触到英格兰的历史。当时让我感到震惊的是，我无法想象法国或美国的学生会以他们的国家被征服、占领和羞辱的记录作为他们国家历史的入门。这说明了我们作为一个民族所拥有的非凡自信和自我确信，我们如此享受
this story so much. Well, it also speaks to the fact that 1066, I mean, it is an incredibly decisive year, and we will be doing a bonus on just how decisive the kind of the long term consequences of 1066. But also, and we again, we talked about this before, it is so dramatic. So it's a showdown between three great warlords, all of whom we've mentioned in our previous episodes. So Harold Hardrada, we've just done two episodes on his extraordinary story. William of Normandy, Harold Godwinson, and each of those are representing three, you know, deeply fascinating, deeply kind of menacing powers. So Viking Scandinavia with its dragon ships and its hard rulers,
这个故事。嗯，这也说明了1066年确实是一个极其决定性的年份，我们将制作一期加餐，专门探讨1066年的长期后果究竟有多么决定性。而且，正如我们之前讨论过的，它实在是太戏剧化了。这是三个伟大军阀之间的对决，我们在之前的剧集中都提到过他们。所以哈拉尔德·哈德拉达，我们刚刚做了两集关于他非凡故事的节目。诺曼底的威廉、哈罗德·戈德温森，他们每个人都代表着三个（你知道的）极其迷人、极具威胁性的势力。比如带有龙船和强硬统治者的维京斯堪的纳维亚，
Normandy with its knights, its castles and Anglo-Saxon England with its mead halls and its mustaches. And a bit like in the Harold Hardrada episode where you have Vikings going to a Roman capital, there is a sense that you, you know, this is a year where a guy who's representing knights and castles is invading an island at the same time as a guy who is having dragon ships and giant axes and things. Yeah. It's again, it's like one of those computer games where people from different periods are kind of rubbing up against each other.
拥有骑士和城堡的诺曼底，以及拥有密德大厅和胡子的盎格鲁-萨克森英格兰。有点像在哈拉尔德·哈德拉达那一集里，维京人前往罗马首都一样，这里有一种感觉，这是一个代表着骑士和城堡的家伙正在入侵一个岛屿的年份，同时还有另一个拥有龙船、巨斧等武器的家伙。是的。这再次像是某种电脑游戏，来自不同时期的不同人物相互碰撞。
Well, it was like, I mean, Game of Thrones, right? Whereas armors from different continents are suddenly all fighting for the same, the iron throne. I mean, this is clearly one of the inspirations for that rival warlords competing with their vast armies that represent different civilizations for one prize and only one is going to win. And that prize is England. And so as the new year dawns, as 1065 slips into history, England is the
嗯，这就像《权力的游戏》，对吧？不同大陆的盔甲突然都在为同一个铁王座而战。我的意思是，这显然是那个故事的灵感来源之一，敌对的军阀带着代表不同文明的庞大军队为同一个奖品展开竞争，而最终只有一个人会获胜。那个奖品就是英格兰。因此，当新年曙光初现，1065年成为历史，英格兰成为了
focus of obsessive interest across the whole of Northern Europe and specifically one place in England, namely Westminster, which previously undistinguished settlement to the west of the city of London, the old Roman city with its great walls. But for several years now, several decades has been a great hive of activity because it is the centre of a massive palace complex, which has been sponsored by Edward the Confessor, King of England for the past two and a half decades. And Westminster is celebrated above all for its Abbey or in old English, it's Minster. So it is a Minster to the west of London. So hence Westminster. And it's an absolutely as Churchill hinted
整个北欧痴迷关注的焦点，具体到英格兰的一个地方，即威斯敏斯特。这里以前是伦敦城（拥有宏伟城墙的古老罗马城市）西部一个并不起眼的定居点。但多年来，几十年来，这里一直是一个巨大的活动中心，因为它是庞大宫殿综合体的中心，该综合体由过去二十五年英格兰国王忏悔者爱德华赞助。威斯敏斯特最著名的莫过于它的修道院，用古英语来说就是它的“明斯特”（Minster）。所以它是伦敦西部的明斯特，因此得名威斯敏斯特（Westminster）。正如丘吉尔在
in that opening. I mean, it is an expression of his piety confessor is a supercate given to him as an indication of his devotion to the church. But it is also an expression of his relative impotence, because Edward the confessor is old, he is sick, he is childless, and for most of his reign, this man who is descended supposedly from Woden via Kurdic, the legendary founder of the West Saxon line, from Alfred the Great, from Athelstan, he has been in the shadow of a single upstart family.
开场白中所暗示的那样，这绝对是。我的意思是，这是他虔诚的表现，“忏悔者”是赋予他的一个尊称，用以表明他对教会的奉献。但这也是他相对无能的表现，因为忏悔者爱德华又老又病，膝下无子，在他统治的大部分时间里，这个据说通过西萨克森血统的传奇奠基人库迪克、通过阿尔弗雷德大帝、通过埃塞尔斯坦追溯到沃登的人，一直生活在一个暴发户家族的阴影之下。
The Godwins. Yeah. So just to remind people, we talked about the Godwins and we talked about Edward the Confessor's reign before we got into Harold Hardrada. So you had Godwin, he was a great collaborator with Cnut wasn't he? Basically a self-made man who had risen as Cnut's, not exactly his right hand, but one of his hands. Subtle, ruthless, plausible. That's like me Tom.
戈德温家族。是的。所以为了提醒大家，我们在进入哈拉尔德·哈德拉达之前，讨论过戈德温家族以及忏悔者爱德华的统治。当时有戈德温，他是克努特的伟大合作者，不是吗？基本上是一个白手起家的人，作为克努特的——不能完全说是右手，但也是他的左臂右膀之一。微妙、冷酷、巧舌如簧。就像我一样，汤姆。
Then you had the Godwinsons. So Harold, he's Earl of Wessex. He's succeeded his father. Yeah, so at the end of 1065, he is the Earl of Wessex. Yeah. And he's got two brothers, both of whom are Earls. So kind of dominant magnates in England. So you've got Gyrth, who is the Earl of East Anglia.
然后是戈德温森家族。哈罗德是威塞克斯伯爵。他继承了他父亲的职位。是的，所以在1065年底，他是威塞克斯伯爵。是的。他有两个兄弟，两人都是伯爵。所以可以说是英格兰的主要权贵。比如吉尔斯，他是东盎格利亚伯爵。
And you have Laerphwine, who is basically Earl of the Home Counties. Right,ofwine who is basically Earl of the Home counties. Right, okay. Yeah, so all those garden centers and things. Right, very nice. And Edith, remind us who Edith is. So Edith is their sister and she is married to Edward the Confessor. Right, yes. And the Abbey really is a way for Edward to sidestep his political impotence
还有勒夫温，他基本上是家郡的伯爵。没错，勒夫温基本上是家郡的伯爵。没错，好的。是的，所有的那些园艺中心之类的。好的，非常好。伊迪丝，提醒我们伊迪丝是谁。伊迪丝是他们的妹妹，她嫁给了忏悔者爱德华。对，没错。修道院对爱德华来说确实是一种方式，可以绕过他在政治上的无能，
and kind of lay down a spiritual marker that he hopes will endure for all time, which up to this point it has done. Westminster Abbey is still standing there. And although the Abbey built by Edward the Confessor was effectively demolished and rebuilt in the reign of Henry III, so several centuries later, nevertheless, the building that Edward the Confessor sponsors is huge. I mean, it is much larger than any building ever before commissioned by an Anglo Saxon king. And so it is a hugely impressive legacy that he knows that he will lead. And by the end of 1065, it's not quite finished.
并立下一个精神上的标记，他希望这个标记能永世长存，而到目前为止它确实做到了。威斯敏斯特修道院至今仍然耸立在那里。尽管忏悔者爱德华建造的修道院在亨利三世统治时期（即几个世纪后）被有效拆除并重建，但忏悔者爱德华赞助的这座建筑依然十分宏大。我的意思是，它比以往任何一位盎格鲁-萨克森国王委托建造的建筑都要大得多。因此，这是一份令他深感自豪、他知道自己将留下的宏伟遗产。到1065年底，它还没有完全完工。
So the porch still needs to be done up, you know, liquor paint, that kind of thing, but it's clear that Edward probably isn't going to see it finished because as Christmas 1065 approaches, he is clearly terminally ill. And so it's decided that the celebration of Christmas should be combined with the dedication of the Abbey so that Edward will get to see it. Okay. So Christmas Day, a great feast is held. Edward presides at the table, but he's really not well. He can only toy with his food. He's not enjoying Christmas in any way.
所以门廊还需要粉刷装饰，你知道，刷点漆之类的，但很明显爱德华可能看不到它完工了，因为随着1065年圣诞节的临近，他显然已经病入膏肓。因此人们决定将圣诞庆典与修道院的奉献仪式结合起来，以便爱德华能够亲眼看到它。好吧。圣诞节当天，举行了一场盛大的宴会。爱德华主持宴会，但他真的很不舒服。他只能百无聊赖地拨弄着食物。他一点也不享受这个圣诞节。
On the 28th of December, which is the day that Westminster Abbey is dedicated, he's too ill to attend the service. And so Edith, his queen, Harold Godwinson's sister stands in for him at the service. And for a week after that, Edward is going downhill, slipping in and out of consciousness, occasionally reviving, muttering about terrible times coming for England. So that's what Churchill was alluding to. And the end comes, as Churchill said, on the 5th of January, 1066. So 5th January, my birthday.
在12月28日，也就是威斯敏斯特修道院奉献的日子里，他病得太重而无法出席仪式。因此，他的王后、哈罗德·戈德温森的妹妹伊迪丝代替他出席了仪式。在此后的一个星期里，爱德华的病情急剧恶化，在清醒和昏迷之间徘徊，偶尔苏醒时，嘴里还喃喃自语着英格兰即将迎来可怕的时代。这就是丘吉尔所暗指的。正如丘吉尔所说，终点在1066年1月5日到来。所以1月5日，我的生日。
So two famous things happen. Yeah, very famous. So Edward is then buried the following day, but that is not the only momentous thing that happens on the sixth of January 1066, because it is notable as well for a great assembly in Westminster of the Witan and the Witan are the great magnates and bishops of England. And of course they had gathered in Westminster for the Christmas celebrations, for the dedication of the Abbey and they had then stayed on partly to celebrate the feast of Epiphany, but also in expectation that the King is going to die because it is their duty to elect the next
所以发生了两件著名的事情。是的，非常著名。爱德华于次日下葬，但这并不是1066年1月6日发生的唯一一件重大事件，因为这一天还因威斯敏斯特召开的“维坦”（Witan，贤人会议）大会而引人注目，“维坦”是英格兰的权贵和主教们。当然，他们聚集在威斯敏斯特是为了庆祝圣诞节、修道院的奉献仪式，他们随后留下来，一部分是为了庆祝主显节，但也因为预料到国王即将驾崩，因为选举下一任国王是他们的职责。
King. The Anglo-Saxon monarchy is elective. Right, let me just stop you there. So the Anglo-Saxon monarchy does not proceed on the automatic assumption that the next person in the, you know, as it would now, the next person in the family tree, automatically, unquestionably gets the crown. There is a degree, there is maybe an expectation that they'll be seriously considered, but there is a degree of flexibility in the arrangements. Is that right?
盎格鲁-萨克森君主制是选举产生的。好吧，让我在这里打断你一下。因此，盎格鲁-萨克森君主制并不遵循这样的自动假设：正如现在这样，家谱中的下一个顺位人会自动、毫无疑问地获得王位。在这些安排中存在一定程度的灵活性，也许人们期望会认真考虑他们，但安排中存在一定的灵活性。是这样吗？
Yes. As you say, the likelihood is, is that the hereditary principle will kick in. But if there is not a suitable candidate to hand, you know, if there is not a sum of eligible age, then discussions are held. So now we have this kind of conclave style scenario where the different. Earls, bishops and whatnot are gathered in Westminster. You know, they have to decide and they have to do it obviously pretty quickly because nobody likes, you know, nature abhors a vacuum. So the Godwinstons are obviously the key players, Harold, Geert and Leofwine.
是的。正如你所说，很可能世袭原则会发挥作用。但如果没有合适的人选在手，你知道，如果没有达到合适年龄的人，就会举行讨论。所以现在我们有了这种类似闭门会议的场景，不同的伯爵、主教等等聚集在威斯敏斯特。你知道，他们必须做出决定，而且显然必须相当快地做出决定，因为没有人喜欢——大自然厌恶真空。因此，戈德温森家族显然是关键人物，哈罗德、吉尔特和勒夫温。
They've never been unchallenged, have they? Because there's always been a counterbalance which is this Mercian dynasty that goes back all the way to what was his name? Leofric. Leofric who was married to Lady Godiva who rode through Coventry naked on a horse. Exactly. So a fun grandmother. And they've been serious players all through this period, the Leofric people. So basically for three generations and in 1066 you've got two heirs to this dynasty and both of them are earls. So you have Edwin the elder brother who is the Earl of Mercia, so that's the Midlands. Yeah. And then you've got Morkar who has just become the Earl of Northumbria
他们从来都不是没有受到挑战的，不是吗？因为一直有一个制衡力量，那就是这个麦西亚王朝，它的历史一直可以追溯到——他叫什么名字？勒夫里克。勒夫里克，他娶了戈黛娃夫人，她曾赤身骑马穿过考文垂。没错。一个有趣的祖母。在整个这一时期，勒夫里克家族一直都是重要的玩家。基本上持续了三代人，而在1066年，这个王朝有两个继承人，而且两人都是伯爵。所以你有长兄埃德温，他是麦西亚伯爵，也就是中部地区。是的。然后你有刚成为诺森布里亚伯爵的莫卡，
and both of these earls are present in Westminster. Kind of adding to the swirl of tensions between the Godwinsons and these two Earls, Edwin and Morka, is the fact that less than two months previously, Edwin and Morka had been in armed and open revolt against the power of the Godwinsons. So scope for tension there. There is also tension in the upper ranks of the church because you've got the bishops, abbots, and the kingdom's two archbishops. And the most senior of the archbishops, the archbishop of Canterbury, a guy called Stigand, the guy who Churchill said had been a close associate of the Godwins. Churchill is not wrong. Stigand basically had been a protege of Earl Godwin. And when Godwin had been driven into
这两位伯爵都出席了威斯敏斯特的会议。加剧戈德温森家族与埃德温和莫卡这两位伯爵之间紧张局势的另一个因素是，就在不到两个月前，埃德温和莫卡曾武装公开起义，反抗戈德温森家族的权力。因此，这里充满了紧张局势的空间。教会高层也存在紧张局势，因为这里有主教、修道院院长和王国两位大主教。资历最深的大主教、坎特伯雷大主教是一个叫斯蒂甘德的人，也就是丘吉尔所说的与戈德温家族关系密切的那个人。丘吉尔并没有错。斯蒂甘德基本上是戈德温伯爵的门生。当戈德温在1051年被忏悔者爱德华驱逐流放时，
temporary exile by Edward the Confessor in 1051, he's said to have wept over the departure of his patron. And when Godwin returns, Edward has brought in a Norman, Robert of Jumierge, to be Archbishop of Canterbury. But when Godwin comes back, Robert of Jumierge flees to the continent and Stigand is installed in Canterbury as his place. The other Archbishop, Ealdred, the Archbishop of York, he too is close to the Godwins, but also had been very, very close to Edward the Confessor and so is a more neutral figure than Stigand. And York itself had been Viking Jororvik a city traditionally very sympathetic to The kind of Scandinavian world quite hostile to the godwinson. So again, there is scope there for kind of tension
据说他曾为他的资助人的离去而痛哭。当戈德温归来时，爱德华引入了一位诺曼人——于米耶日 的罗伯特担任坎特伯雷大主教。但当戈德温回来时，于米耶日 的罗伯特逃到了欧洲大陆，斯蒂甘德随即在坎特伯雷就职以取而代之。另一位大主教、约克大主教埃尔德雷德，他也与戈德温家族亲近，但同时也与忏悔者爱德华非常非常亲近，因此比斯蒂甘德更像是一个中立人物。约克本身曾是维京人的约尔维克（Jorvik），这是一个传统上非常同情斯堪的纳维亚世界、对戈德温森家族相当敌视的城市。因此，这里同样存在产生紧张局势的空间。
So this is the balance of forces these people assemble on the 6th of january and as they survey the scene They effectively have three main candidates. I would say, to for the throne of England. Well, possibly four, possibly four, let's say three and a half. Okay. So they've lived in the shadow of a conquest already, which is the conquest of Cnut in 1016. So from the moment they assemble, they must be thinking, well, we don't want that to happen again. Yeah. And there is a slight possibility that could happen again, isn't there? Because they know that there is a very powerful contender across the North Sea in Norway and that person is Harald Hardrada and he does have a little bit of a claim, doesn't he?
这就是各种力量的平衡，这些人于1月6日集会，当他们审视局势时，他们实际上有三位主要候选人，可以说，来竞争英格兰的王位。嗯，可能还有四个，可能四个，我们算三位半吧。好吧。他们已经生活在一次征服的阴影之下了，那就是1066年克努特的征服。因此，从他们集会的那一刻起，他们一定在想，好吧，我们可不想让这种事再次发生。是的。而且确实有那么一点可能性会再次发生，不是吗？因为他们知道在北海对面的挪威有一个非常强大的竞争者，那个人就是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达，他确实有一点点继承权，不是吗？
Harold Hardrada. Kind of, because there had been an agreement back in the days of the because there had been an agreement back in the days of the succession conflict between Arthur Canute and Magnus, who had been the King of Norway, that if either one of them died without an heir, then the other would become successor to that person's kingdom. So there is just a sniff of a claim that Harold Hardrada might be able to leverage. But I think it's generally felt implausible and there's no real suggestion that Harald Hardrada is interested in the English throne. Then there is another Scandinavian king in the form of Svein Estridsson, who is the nephew
哈拉尔德·哈德拉达。有点算吧，因为在……因为在当年的继承权冲突时期曾有过一项协议，即克努特和挪威国王马格努斯达成协议，如果他们两人中有一人无嗣而终，那么另一人将成为那个王国继承人。因此，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达确实有一丝可以利用的继承权。但我认为人们普遍觉得这不太可能，而且也没有真正的迹象表明哈拉尔德·哈德拉达对英格兰王位感兴趣。然后还有另一个斯堪的纳维亚国王，斯文·埃斯特里德森，他是克努特的侄子，
of Canute and who, you know, people in England are well aware of how predatory Canute's family can be. You know, might he fancy coming back and getting his uncle's kingdom? But I guess they think the Norwegians and the Danes have been fighting each other in the war which we described last week as one of the most boring wars in history. So they probably think, well, then they're too busy worrying about each other. Yeah.
英格兰的人们很清楚克努特的家族是多么具有掠夺性。你知道，他会不会想回来夺取他叔叔的王国？但我想他们会认为挪威人和丹麦人一直在互相打仗，我们在上周将其描述为历史上最无聊的战争之一。所以他们可能认为，好吧，他们太忙于互相提防了，
To be interested in England. And the bottom line is they don't want a Viking King. I mean, they've had enough of Viking kings. Then another candidate, of course, is William, the Duke of Normandy. And he has several kind of pros in his favor. So Edward almost certainly had promised him the throne 15 years previously when the Godwins had been in exile, the Godwins had then come back, of course, Harold Godwinson had ended up exile, the Godwins had then come back, of course, Harold Godwinson had ended up in the hands of William and had sworn on the bones of saints that he would support William's claim to the throne. And everyone in England knows that
以至于对英格兰不感兴趣。最重要的是，他们不想要一个维京国王。我的意思是，他们已经受够了维京国王了。那么另一个候选人，当然是诺曼底公爵威廉。他有好几个有利于他的优势。所以爱德华在15年前戈德温家族被流放时，几乎可以肯定向他承诺过王位，当然，戈德温家族后来回来了，哈罗德·戈德温森最终落入了威廉手中，并在圣徒遗骨上发誓他将支持威廉对王位的宣称。英格兰的所有人都知道，
William is a ruthless and brilliant soldier and that there is a very, very strong risk that if he is denied the throne, then he will invade what he sees as his rightful kingdom. So that is something else to bear in mind, but there is again, a huge con, which is that just as the, the Witan don't want a Scandinavian King, they don't want a Norman King either. Well, they're probably even less keen on a Norman King because a Scandinavian King would be at least a vaguely known quantity, whereas the Normans represent something unsettling and new, right?
威廉是一位冷酷无情、才华横溢的军人，如果剥夺他的王位，他很有可能会入侵他视之为自己合法王国的领土。所以这也是需要记住的一点，但同样有一个巨大的劣势，那就是就像“维坦”不想要一个斯堪的纳维亚国王一样，他们也不想要一个诺曼国王。嗯，他们可能对诺曼国王更加反感，因为斯堪的纳维亚国王至少是一个依稀了解的变量，而诺曼人代表着某种令人不安的新事物，对吧？
Well, I mean, the Normans have been part of English life because William's great aunt Emma, of course, had married Athelred, so they are there. But I think what they've seen of the Normans, they don't really like. So yes, they don't want William either. So what about another descendant of Kurdic and Alfred? Alfred the great, right. So there are a few people hanging around from that family on that. Because although Edward the confessor famously had no children, he does have a nephew. So Edmund Ironside, so people may remember him from the series we did before
嗯，我的意思是，诺曼人一直是英国生活的一部分，因为威廉的姑奶奶艾玛当然嫁给了埃塞尔德雷德，所以他们一直都在那里。但我认为他们所看到的诺曼人，他们其实并不喜欢。所以是的，他们也不想要威廉。那么库迪克和阿尔弗雷德的另一个后裔呢？阿尔弗雷德大帝，对吧？所以那个家族里还有几个人在四处游荡。因为尽管忏悔者爱德华大名鼎鼎却没有孩子，但他有一个侄子。所以埃德蒙·艾恩赛德（ Ironside），人们可能还记得我们在哈拉尔德·哈德拉达之前制作的关于盎格鲁-萨克森最后日期的系列节目，埃德蒙·艾恩赛德有一个儿子叫爱德华，他去了匈牙利。
Harold Hardrada on the kind of last days of Anglo-Saxon, Edmund Ironside had a son called Edward who'd gone off to Hungary. Yes, where he gets to be called by the English Edward the Exile and he had married Agatha who may well have been the sister-in-law of Harold Hardrada. So we were talking about the strange networks of marriage alliance that span the whole of Europe. And Edward the Confessor had definitely wanted to groom this nephew as his heir. So in 1054, he had sent Ealdred, who in due course is going to become the Archbishop of York, to go and fetch Edward the Exile. But Edward the Exile doesn't want to come. I mean, he's basically a Hungarian exile. He's perfectly happy, eating his goulash, whatever. He doesn't want to come over. So 1056, two years later, it's the turn of Harold Godwinson to go and try and sort things out. So he travels to the continent and this time he is successful and
是的，英国人称他为流亡者爱德华，他娶了阿加莎，阿加莎很可能是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的小姨子。所以我们刚才在谈论跨越整个欧洲的奇怪婚姻同盟网络。忏悔者爱德华绝对曾想把这个侄子培养为自己的继承人。因此在1054年，他派遣了埃尔德雷德（日后将成为约克大主教）去接回流亡者爱德华。但流亡者爱德华不想来。我的意思是，他基本上是个匈牙利的流亡者。他过得很开心，吃着他的古洛什汤，什么的。他不想过来。所以在1056年，两年后，轮到哈罗德·戈德温森去尝试整顿事情了。于是他前往欧洲大陆，这一次他成功了，
the following year in 1057, Edward the exile arrives in England and he's been there for about two days. He hasn't even met Edward the confessor and he dies. He drops dead. So another another mysterious death and he leaves behind two daughters and crucially one son, a guy called Edgar. So what about Edgar? He's still on the scene. He's clearly what the English call atheling, which essentially means that you're eligible to inherit the throne.
第二年，即1057年，流亡者爱德华抵达英格兰，他在那里待了两天左右。他甚至还没见到忏悔者爱德华就死了。他突然倒地身亡。所以又是一起神秘的死亡，他留下了两个女儿，至关重要的是还有一个儿子，一个叫埃德加的人。那么埃德加呢？他仍然在场。他显然是英国人所说的“埃特林”（Atheling），这基本上意味着你有资格继承王位。
So he's called Edgar Atheling. He's been raised by Edith, so maybe he'd be acceptable to the Godwinsons. But there is a massive problem and that is that he's only 13. And the Witanat are agreed, I think, that if they're going to ignore the claim of William, then they will need a honed warrior who is able to defend his throne and his kingdom. And that in effect means that there is only one candidate. And that person, Tom, is obviously Harold Godwinson, the Earl of Wessex. But just before Harold Godwinson, so they know that they're going to face an invasion, right? Which means that they must take William's claim very, very seriously and at least know that William takes it incredibly seriously. So right at this point, they know if we don't choose William,
所以他被称为埃特林·埃德加。他是被伊迪丝抚养长大的，所以也许戈德温森家族会接受他。但这里有一个巨大的问题，那就是他只有13岁。我认为“维坦”一致认为，如果他们要忽视威廉的主张，他们就需要一个经验丰富的勇士，能够保卫他的王位和王国。这意味着实际上只有一个候选人。而那个人，汤姆，显然就是威塞克斯伯爵哈罗德·戈德温森。但在哈罗德·戈德温森之前——他们知道自己将面临入侵，对吧？这意味着他们必须非常非常严肃地对待威廉的主张，并且至少知道威廉对此极其重视。所以在此时此刻，他们知道如果我们不选择威廉，
he is definitely going to invade. Is that fair? I think that is almost certainly their perspective. Yes. It depends really how opposed they are to a Norman King. Are they sufficiently opposed that they are prepared to risk invasion? And if they are, then they have to choose someone who is able to withstand that invasion. I mean, that is essentially the bind they find themselves in. And it is clearly the case that there are problems with choosing Harold. So firstly, he may be the brother-in-law of Edward the Confessor, but he has no blood link to the traditional royal line of the West Saxon monarchy. He's
他绝对会入侵。这样说公平吗？我认为这几乎肯定是他们的观点。是的。这实际上取决于他们对诺曼国王的反对程度有多深。他们的反对是否强烈到让他们准备好冒着被入侵的风险？如果是的话，那么他们就必须选择一个能够抵御这种入侵的人。我的意思是，这基本上就是他们发现自己陷入的困境。而且很明显，选择哈罗德存在问题。首先，他可能是忏悔者爱德华的内兄，但他与西萨克森君主制的传统王室血脉没有任何血缘关系。他不是阿尔弗雷德大帝的直系后裔，就像埃特林·埃德加那样。因此，解决这个问题的办法是坚称忏悔者爱德华在病榻上指定了哈罗德。我们没有关于忏悔者爱德华说了什么的最终版本记录。因此，有《盎格鲁-萨克森编年史》的各种版本，这是用古英语随着事件发生而编写的历史记录，其中有两个版本的《盎格鲁-萨克森编年史》说爱德华将英格兰交托给哈罗德保护。那么这是否意味着他任命哈罗德为国王，或者也许
not a lineal descendant of Alfred the Great as say Edgar the Atheling is. So the solution to this problem is to insist that Edward the Confessor had nominated Harold on his sick bed. And we have no definitive account of what Edward the confessor said. So there are kind of various versions of the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, which is the historical record that is being written as events happen in Old English. And two versions of the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle say that Edward appointed England to Harold's protection. So does that mean he's appointing Harold as king or perhaps
任命他为埃特林·埃德加的摄政王？我的意思是，这并不清楚，但《盎格鲁-萨克森编年史》的一个版本确实说爱德华明确授予了哈罗德王位。有趣的是，实际上诺曼人倾向于承认这一点，我们拥有的诺曼历史学家也是如此。贝约挂毯（Bayes Tapestry）是1066年事件的关键来源，这是一系列描绘当年事件的伟大插图。画面中展示了忏悔者爱德华躺在病榻上与他的顾问交谈。然后在下一幅插图中，有点像连环画，其中一个人随后向哈罗德献上王冠，他指着前面忏悔者爱德华与床边的人交谈的插图。这表明爱德华曾说过，去把王冠交给哈罗德，然后你就会看到
as regent for Edgar Ratholing? I mean, it's unclear, but there is one version of the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle which does say that Edward specifically granted Harold the throne. And what's interesting is that actually the Normans tend to acknowledge this, the Norman historians we have. And the Beow Tapestry, which is a key source for the events of 1066, this great kind of series of illustrations showing the events of that year. And we are shown Edward the Confessor lying on his deathbed and speaking to his advisors. And then in the next illustration, so it's a bit like a strip cartoon, you have one of the men who is then offering Harold the crown, pointing back at this illustration of Edward the Confessor talking to the people around his bedside. So suggesting that Edward has said, go and give the crown to Harold and then you see
王冠被交给了哈罗德。因此，“维坦”显然认为，好吧，这意味着足够的合法性。现在的问题是，埃德温和莫卡怎么办？这两位伯爵属于传统上一直是戈德温森家族死敌的家族。我认为很明显他们在爱德华死前就已经被安抚了。这的证明是，就在“维坦”选举哈罗德为国王后不久，他娶了他们的妹妹，听众们
the crown being given to Harold. So the Witton obviously think, well, I mean, that's sufficient legitimacy. Now the question is, what about Edwin and Morka? Who are the, the two worlds who belong to the family that traditionally have been the great rival of the Godwinson's? I think it's pretty clear that they have been squared before Edward dies. And the proof of this is that very shortly after the Witton elect Harold as King, he marries their sister and listeners will
一定会高兴地知道，这位妹妹的名字也叫伊迪丝。所以哈罗德的妹妹叫伊迪丝。他的妻子，（你知道的）埃德温和莫卡的妹妹叫伊迪丝，而他的女朋友兼情人兼妻子兼情妇兼随便你叫她什么的女人也叫伊迪丝，她拥有一个宏伟的名字：天鹅颈。所以天鹅颈伊迪丝，哈罗德效仿丹麦国王的最佳传统——因为他有一半丹麦血统，他的母亲是丹麦人——将天鹅颈伊迪丝放在一边，但仍然和她住在一起。但他现在也有了埃德温和莫卡的妹妹伊迪丝作为王后，这对他的名字来说有点混乱，但依然和她住在一起，不过他现在也有了埃德温和莫卡的妹妹伊迪丝作为王后。对他来说有点混乱，但也挺方便，因为她们名字都一样。
be thrilled to know that the name of this sister is also Edith. So Harold's sister is called Edith. His wife, you know, the sister of Edwin and Morka is called Edith and his girlfriend stroke, concubine stroke, wife stroke, mistress stroke, whatever you want to call it is also called Edith and she has rejoices in the magnificent name of swan neck. So Edith swan neck and Harold in the kind of the best tradition of Danish Kings because he is half Danish. His mother is Danish sets Edith swan neck aside, but still lives with her. But he now also has Edith sister of Edwin and Morka is his queen kind of confusing for him, but still lives with her, but he now also has Edith, sister of Edwin of Morca as its queen. Kind of confusing for him, but also convenient they're both of the same name.
差不多吧。我想这有助于过情人节。是的。当然，如果哈罗德和埃德温与莫卡的妹妹伊迪丝生下一个儿子，那么他将联合英格兰两个伟大的敌对王朝。你知道，那将是绝妙的。我们提到哈罗德曾在圣徒遗骨上发誓他会支持威廉
Kind of. Yeah. It helps with Valentine's Day, I guess. Yeah. And of course, if Harold and Edith, the sister of Edwin of Morca have a son, then he will unite the two great rival dynasties of England. You know, so that would be brilliant. We mentioned that Harold has sworn an oath on the bones of saints that he will back William's
对王位的要求，这确实要求他违背誓言。但有一种感觉是，哈罗德是一个受誓言约束较少的人，可能不如一个传统上更具宗教信仰的人那样受束缚。我认为这很好地反映了哈罗德的性格。他就像是，好吧，随便，谁在乎呢？他对圣徒遗骨的态度和我对它们的态度一样，汤姆，我认为这样说很公平。所以这很绝妙，尽管在另一方面并不绝妙，因为正如你所说，哈罗德一定知道，正如其他人所知的那样，一旦他接受了王冠，这就使得入侵变得几乎无可避免。
claim to the throne and it does require him to break that. But there is a sense that Harold is a man who is less bound by oaths than perhaps a more conventionally religious person would be. I think this reflects very well on Harold. He's like, yeah, whatever, who cares? He takes the same attitude towards the bones of saints that I would Tom, I think it's fair to say. So brilliant, though, though not brilliant in another way, because as you say, Harold must know, as everybody else knows, that once he accepts the crown, it makes invasion as close to inevitable as you're going to
所以想必这就是为什么他们如此匆忙，他们想速战速决，并继续进行军事准备。因此哈罗德于1月6日（他被选中的那一天）加冕，这非常不寻常。国王被选举和加冕之间通常会有更长的时间间隔。这种仓促经常被形容为“不得体”，但我一点也不觉得不得体。我认为这是完全可以理解的，因为每个人都知道他作为国王的地位必须以最快的速度彰显出来。而且“维坦”全员都在威斯敏斯特现场见证加冕典礼。尽管
get. So presumably, that's why they're in a great rush, they want to get this done and dusted and they get on with their military preparations. So Harold is crowned on the 6th of January, the day he is chosen, and this is very unusual. There's usually a kind of much longer separation of time between a king being elected and being crowned. And the haste is often described as unseemly, but I don't think it's unseemly at all. I think it's entirely understandable because everyone knows that his status as king has to be made manifest absolutely as soon as possible. And also the Witan are all on hand in Westminster to witness the coronation. And although
我们没有被告知他是在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕的，但他几乎肯定是在那里加冕的，可能是第一位在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕的国王。因此，哈罗德现在拥有——他已经加冕，他已经受膏。他有充分的理由证明他是一位合法的国王。他据称是由忏悔者指定的。他被选举了。他受膏了。但正如你所说，这种合法性是他需要穿戴的盔甲的关键部分，因为他知道他对英格兰的统治绝对会遭到攻击。事实上，不仅仅来自威廉，因为选举哈罗德为国王对其他人来说也是一块红布，那是某个潜伏在海峡彼岸、对哈罗德怀恨在心并决心报仇的人。
we're not told that he's crowned in Westminster Abbey, he almost certainly is probably the first king to be crowned in Westminster Abbey. And so Harold now has, you know, he's been crowned, he's been anointed. He has a good case to make that he is a legitimate king. He's been supposedly nominated by the confessor. He's been elected. He's been anointed. But as you say, that legitimacy is a crucial part of the armour that he needs to put on because he knows that his rule of England is absolutely going to come under attack. And in fact, not just from William, because the election of Harold as King is a red rag as well to someone else, someone who has been lurking beyond the channel, twisted with hatred for Harold and resolved to have his
对，这就是哈罗德的兄弟托斯蒂格。给我们讲讲托斯蒂格吧。所以我们提到莫卡在1066年晚秋之前才成为诺森布里亚伯爵，他是在托斯蒂格（哈罗德自己的兄弟）卸任后继任为诺森布里亚伯爵的，托斯蒂格此前被诺森布里亚人和麦西亚人（由莫卡和埃德温共同领导）的联盟驱逐流放。托斯蒂格不仅被逼离开职位，还被迫流放，他对被推翻的意外和迅速感到绝对震惊。他坚信幕后黑手其实就是他自己的亲兄弟，
revenge. Right and this is Harold's brother Tostig. So tell us a little bit about Tostig. So we mentioned how Morkar has been Earl of Northumbria only since the late autumn of 1066 and he has become Earl of Northumbria in succession to Tostig, Harold's own brother, who had been forced into exile by an alliance between the Northumbrians and the Mercians, led jointly by Morkar and by Edwin. And Tostig had been forced not just from office, but into exile and absolutely stunned by the unexpectedness and rapidity of his overthrow. He's convinced himself that actually the person behind it was his own brother,
哈罗德。当然，哈罗德迎娶埃德温和莫卡（这两个推翻了他的人）的妹妹这一情景，更加坚定了托斯蒂格内心的黑暗猜疑，就像故事中的几乎所有人一样，他想要东山再起。他不满足于流放。他逃到了法兰德斯，部分是因为那里很近，部分因为被流放英格兰的人去法兰德斯是传统，也因为他的妻子来自法兰德斯，实际上诺曼底公爵的妻子也是如此。有报道称托斯蒂格曾向诺曼底公爵示好并拜访过他。
Harold, and of course the spectacle of Harold marrying the sister of Edwin and Morka, the two men who had overthrown him only confirms Tostig in his darkest suspicions and like pretty much everyone else in the story, he wants to make a comeback. He is not content with exile. And he has fled to Flanders, partly because it's very close, partly because it's traditional for people in exile from England to go to Flanders, but also because his wife is from Flanders, as actually is the wife of William of Normandy. And there is a tradition that's reported that Tostig had made overtures to the Duke of Normandy and had visited him.
还有另一份报告，大概在1066年之后的三十、四十年，称他曾航行到丹麦，试图说服斯文加入他的入侵。这绝对给人一种感觉，即托斯蒂格正在四处寻找盟友，显然托斯蒂格和威廉一样一心想着复仇，并渴望无论在哪里都能获得支持。那么这一切对英格兰意味着什么呢？因为这意味着不仅有威廉带来的迫在眉睫的威胁，还有来自斯堪的纳维亚可能发动攻击的威胁（尽管目前看来不太可能），同时还有托斯蒂格在周围虎视眈眈。随着月份的流逝，必然存在一种巨大的不确定感、焦虑感，甚至可以说是恐惧感。
There is also another report, probably three, four decades after 1066, that says that he had sailed to Denmark to try and persuade Svein to join with him in that invasion definite sense that Tostig is kind of looking around for for allies and it is evident that Tostig like William is out for vengeance and is keen to obtain backing for it wherever he can find it. So what does all this mean for England because it means not only is that the looming threat of William there is the possible threats at this point seems quite unlikely of an attack from Scandinavia, but there's also Tostig hanging around. So there must be a massive sense of uncertainty, anxiety, dare I say dread as the months pass.
是的。接着复活节来了又去，所以作战季节现在降临到了英格兰。正是在那时，正如《盎格鲁-萨克森编年史》在1066年的条目中所记录的那样，英格兰各地都出现了一种奇异的景象，这是前所未有的人们从未目睹过的。有人称之为彗星，其他人称之为“头星”，它引发了巨大的恐惧，没有什么比一颗拖着火尾的星星日复一日地在天空中燃烧，更能作为迫在眉睫的危机的绝对确凿的预兆了。天哪，多么可怕的时刻！所以那是哈雷彗星，对吧？哈雷彗星出现了。每个人都知道这意味着什么。
Yeah. And then Easter comes and goes, so the campaigning season is now upon England. And then it was, as the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle recorded in its entry for 1066, that a portent was seen all over England, such as no man had ever witnessed before. Some called it a comet, others the head star and it generates much dread and there is no more infallible portent of a looming crisis than a fiery tailed star blazing day after day across the sky. Oh my word what a terrifying moment so that's Halley's Comet isn't it? Halley's Comet has isn't it? Halley's Comet has appeared. Everybody knows what that means.
血光之灾即将来临。你知道吗？中场休息后我们可能还会有一点血光之灾。到时见。《历史的其余部分》本期节目由 InvestEngine 赞助播出。投资的更聪明的途径。汤姆，众所周知，历史上充满了极其糟糕的财务决策。南海泡沫、郁金香狂热，我还需要继续列举吗？这就是
Bloodshed is coming. And you know what? We might have a little bit of it after the break. See you then. This episode of The Rest is History is brought to you by InvestEngine. The smarter way to invest. Now Tom, as we know, history is full of spectacularly bad financial decisions. The South Sea bubble, tulip mania, do I need to go on? And that's
InvestEngine 发挥作用的地方，它能帮助你比他们更聪明地投资。没有高额费用，没有花招，只有简单自动化的投资。所以不要轻信糟糕的建议。前往 investengine.com/History 或使用促销代码 history，即可获得最高 100 英镑的欢迎奖金。在限时优惠期间，如果您将 ISA 转入或投资于他们的养老账户，他们还提供最高 4,000 英镑的额外奖金。投资价值可升可跌，本金面临风险，最低存款额为 100 英镑，您必须保持投资至少 12 个月才能保留奖金。InvestEngine UK Limited 获得金融行为监管局（FCA）授权并受其监管，FRN 编号为 801128。
where InvestEngine comes in to help you invest smarter than them. No high fees, no gimmicks, just easy automated investing. So don't fall for bad advice. Head to invest engine comm History or use the promo code history for a welcome bonus of up to 100 pounds For a limited time. They're also offering a further bonus of up to 4,000 pounds if you transfer your ISA or invest in their pension account The value investments can go up or down, capital at risk, minimum deposit of a hundred pounds and you must remain invested for at least 12 months to retain the bonus. InvestEngine UK Limited is authorized and regulated by the Financial Conduct Authority FRN 801128.
这就是InvestEngine可以帮助你比他们更聪明地投资的地方。没有高额费用，没有花招，只有简单的自动化投资。所以不要轻信不良建议。前往investengine.com/history或使用促销代码history，即可获得高达100英镑的欢迎奖金。在限时活动期间，如果您转移ISA或投资其养老账户，他们还提供高达4000英镑的额外奖金。投资价值可升可跌，本金存在风险，最低存款为100英镑，您必须至少投资12个月才能保留奖金。InvestEngine UK Limited获得英国金融行为监管局（FCA）授权并受其监管，FRN为801128。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the weeks after Easter 1066. England has just been visited by Halley's Comet. So Halley's Comet was named after the astronomer Edward Halley who in 1705 calculated that this comet reappeared about every 75 years. However, that's not how people view it in 1066, is it Tom? Because they say Comet disaster is coming. Yeah, absolutely. And sure enough, even as the tale of the Comet is flickering away into the inky vastnesses of space, ominous news is being brought to Harold from the Isle of Wight. The Isle of Wight? Oh no, that's the place you don't want to get news from.
欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。现在是1066年复活节后的几周。英格兰刚刚迎来了哈雷彗星。哈雷彗星是以天文学家爱德华·哈雷的名字命名的，他在1705年计算出这颗彗星大约每75年重新出现一次。然而，在1066年，人们并不是这样看待它的，对吧，汤姆？因为他们说彗星灾难要来了。是的，完全如此。而且果不其然，就在彗星的尾巴在漆黑辽阔的太空中渐渐隐去之际，威特岛传来了给哈罗德的不祥消息。威特岛？哦，不，那是你最不想听到坏消息的地方。
So it is reported that an enemy fleet has landed there and extorted money and provisions. Is it the Normans? No, it's not the Normans. It's Tostig. So to quote the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle from the Isle of Wight, he then sailed onwards and ravaged everywhere he could make landing along the south coast until he came to Sandwich. But at Sandwich he finds that Harold is ready for him, that Harold has gathered again, to quote the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, a larger force both in terms of ships and land forces
据报道，一支敌方舰队在那里登陆，并勒索了金钱和给养。是诺曼人吗？不，不是诺曼人。是托斯蒂格。引用《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中关于威特岛的记载，他随后继续航行，并在南海岸任何可以登陆的地方进行肆虐和破坏，直到来到三明治镇。但在三明治镇，他发现哈罗德已经严阵以待，哈罗德再次集结了——引用《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》的话——一支无论在船只还是陆军数量上都
as no king in England had ever done before. So Tostig feels, well, I can't make a landing here. So he press gangs, sailors from Sandwich and the coast around it to serve in his fleet. And he then heads northwards and he sails with 60 ships, we're told by the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle up the Humber and he starts ravaging Lincolnshire. But Edwin and Moorke, his great Bane, the two people who kicked him out, they raise the various kind of levies from their own lands and they confront him and Tosti finds his own men melting away. So it's evident that, you know, the people of Mercia and Northumbria want nothing to
空前庞大的军队，这是英格兰任何国王都未曾做过的。因此托斯蒂格觉得，好吧，我在这里无法登陆。于是他在三明治镇及周边海岸强征水手加入他的舰队。随后他率领60艘船向北进发，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》告诉我们，他沿亨伯河驶入并开始蹂躏林肯郡。但是埃德温和莫克尔，他的死敌，那两个把他赶走的人，从他们自己的领地召集了各种征召兵来对抗他，结果托斯蒂格发现自己的人马纷纷溃散。显然，你知道，麦西亚和诺森布里亚的人民根本不
do with him. Basically everybody hates him. Everyone hates him. Yeah. And so he escapes the Humber and we're told that, you know, what had been a fleet of 60 ships is now only 12 ships. And so according to the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, and there are later sources, which give further detail and we'll be coming to them in our next episode. But according to the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, he then sales northwards for
想和他有任何瓜葛。基本上所有人都恨他。所有人都恨他。是的。于是他逃出了亨伯河，我们被告知，曾经有60艘船的舰队现在只剩下12艘船了。因此，根据《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》以及提供更多细节的后来的资料——我们将在下一集中讲到它们——但根据《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》，他随后向北航行前往
Scotland and the court of King Malcolm. Yeah. Of course it succeeded to the throne in the wake of the overthrow of Macbeth. And this is very humiliating for Tostick because Malcolm had, had swallowed up a large chunk of his old him of Northumbria in the form of Cumbria, the Lake district. And he'd raided Lindisfarne, you know, and now Tostick's having to go and kind
苏格兰和马尔科姆国王的宫廷。是的。当然，马尔科姆是在麦克白被推翻之后继承王位的。这对于托斯蒂格来说非常羞辱，因为马尔科姆吞并了他旧诺森布里亚王国的一大块领地，也就是坎布里亚和湖区。马尔科姆还袭击了林迪斯法恩，你知道的，现在托斯蒂格不得不去那种地方，
of, you know what he's like is like Ted Cruz paying homage to Donald Trump. Isn't that is what he's like. Yeah. Yeah. And you know, maybe this is the end of the road for him doesn't really seem a comeback does a or is it we will see. Right. So Harold has this big force that he has assembled to defend his kingdom.
你知道他的样子就像特德·克鲁斯向唐纳德·特朗普献媚一样。难道不是吗？他现在就是这个样子。对，对。你知道，也许这是他走投无路了，看起来并不像卷土重来，对吧？或者说事实究竟如何，我们拭目以待。好了，哈罗德聚集了这支庞大的军队来保卫他的王国。
He has raised the feared he's raised the levies. And of course he's done it partly because, you know, Tostig is hanging around, but there is a much more formidable opponent than Tostig. And this of course is William of Normandy. And Harold, everybody should remember, has met William of Normandy. He has been to Normandy when he was messing around with the Saints bones and stuff. He has seen at first hand how formidable the Norman war and how modern the Norman war machine is with its knights It's cavalry its castles and so on so he must really you know, he knows this is going to be a very very stern test
他征召了民兵，他征召了征召兵。当然，他这样做部分是因为托斯蒂格在周围晃荡，但有一个比托斯蒂格更可怕的对手。这当然就是诺曼底的威廉。每个人都应该记得，哈罗德曾与诺曼底的威廉见过面。当他在摆弄圣徒遗骨之类的东西时，他曾去过诺曼底。他亲眼见证了诺曼战争是多么可怕，诺曼战争机器是多么现代化，拥有骑士、骑兵、城堡等等，所以他心里一定很清楚，他知道这将是一场非常非常严峻的考验。
Yeah, and I think there can be no doubt that Churchill writing about this must have felt a sense of identification with Harold Yeah, and what happens in due course? Must have cast a slight shadow. Um, because William, when he has brought the news of Harold's election as King is furious and he sees it not just as a political challenge, but directly as a personal affront. So we know what his response to this is because we have an account of 1066 and its aftermath by a knight who had served William and then gone on to become his personal chaplain, a
是的，毫无疑问，丘吉尔在撰写这段历史时，一定对哈罗德有一种强烈的认同感。是的，随之而来的事件，
man called William of Poitiers. And William of Poitiers writes, Duke William, having consulted his men, decided to avenge this offense, so the events of Harold's election, and regain his inheritance by force of arms, despite many who used clever arguments to dissuade him from such an arduous enterprise as being well beyond the power of the Norman forces. So you have there resolve from William, but also clearly a certain nervousness on the part of many of the people in his court and the broader dukedom. So to look at the nervousness first, why would there be so many in Normandy anxious that they lack the capabilities to conquer
一定投下了一丝阴影。嗯，因为威廉在听到哈罗德被选为国王的消息时勃然大怒，他不仅仅把这看作是一次政治挑战，更是直接视为对个人的侮辱。所以我们知道他对这件事的反应，因为我们有一份关于1066年及其后果的记录，作者是一位曾效力于威廉后来成为其私人随身神父的骑士，
England? William of Patiers is very contemptuous of them. He says, inspired by cowardice, they exaggerated in discussions the strength of Harold's army and the weakness of their own But actually, you know the Normans who are nervous about attacking England are not wrong to be nervous Because as we've been talking throughout the first series we've been doing on this England is a very wealthy and powerful Kingdom it has a very precociously Kingdom it has a very precociously efficient system of government and it has a military infrastructure to match and it may surprise listeners to hear this insisted upon because England was conquered in 1016 by Cnut and there have been succession crises and there's lots of been lots of internal feuding so could you not look at England from Normandy and say well they
一个名叫普瓦捷的威廉的人。普瓦捷的威廉写道：“威廉公爵在同手下人商议后，决定为这一冒犯复仇——即哈罗德当选的事件——并以武力夺回他的继承权，尽管有许多人巧舌如簧地劝阻他放弃这样一项艰巨的事业，认为这远远超出了诺曼军队的力量。”所以你在威廉身上看到了坚定的决心，但显然他朝廷中的许多人和更广泛的公国里也有某种程度的紧张不安。那么先来看看这种不安，为什么诺曼底会有这么多人担心他们没有能力征服
lost you know exactly 50 years ago they were conquered conquered, so it's doable. Plus, you know, a lot of these earls actually hate each other, we might be able to pay them off, you know, once we get in, this might not be so difficult after all, that would be my counter argument. But I think the other way of looking at it is to say, England has gone through conquest, it has gone through all these upheavals and turbulence, and yet the frameworks of governance and the military infrastructure, which had been set up by Alfred the Great, honed by his heirs, they are still going strong. So because of these reforms that Alfred had set in place, and which have endured for almost two centuries now, the depths of manpower that an English king can command and muster remains extremely impressive
英格兰呢？普瓦捷的威廉对他们十分轻蔑。他说，在怯懦的驱使下，他们在讨论中夸大了哈罗德军队的实力和他们自己的软弱。但实际上，你知道，那些担心进攻英格兰的诺曼底人感到紧张并非没有道理，因为正如我们在本系列第一部分中一直讨论的那样，英格兰是一个非常富有且强大的王国，它拥有一个非常早熟且高效的政府系统，并且拥有与之相匹配的军事基础设施。听众听到这一点被反复强调可能会感到惊讶，因为英格兰在1016年曾被克努特征服过，而且经历过王位继承危机，还有过很多内部争斗，所以难道你不能从诺曼底的角度来看待英格兰，然后说，好吧，他们
and much greater than anything that a Norman Duke could do. And under a competent king, which Harold definitely is, there are armies potentially in the tens of thousands that can be summoned. And we know this because we have a record of the military obligations that are imposed upon the various Lords of the kingdom. So to be the Lord of an estate, a Thane, is to owe military service. So to quote from an early 11th century tract about this, to equip freemen with arms and to stand century on the coast and to guard one's Lord. Now that Lord might be the King, but it might equally not be. Like an Earl or something.
在50年前不是刚刚被征服过吗？他们输了，你知道的，就在整整50年前，所以这是可以做到的。另外，你知道，这些伯爵实际上互相仇恨，一旦我们打进去，也许我们可以收买他们，这也许并没有想象中那么困难，这会是我的反驳观点。但我想另一种看法是：英格兰经历过征服，经历过所有这些动荡和风暴，然而由阿尔弗雷德大帝建立、由他的继承人打磨的治理框架和军事基础设施，依然在强劲运行。正因为阿尔弗雷德建立并延续了将近两个世纪的这些改革，英格兰国王能够调集和召集的兵源深度依然极其惊人，
Yeah. The king doesn't own all the lands. There are Earls who have their own lands. And so there are lots of Thanes who own duties to, I don't know, Gith or Morkar or whatever. And these Lords, they're Thanes, many of the kind of the wealthier freemen, the Charles as they're called, you know, these would be quite as well armored as Norman knights. They'd be skilled in the use of swords, of spears, of axes. They would even own horses. In addition to these men who can be raised as needed, the king would have paid specialist troops. So the equivalent, I guess, of the Varangians who defend the emperor in Constantinople. And these are the Housecarls, which is a celebrated name. I mean, anyone who knows anything about Hastings knows about the Housecarls. And again,
远大于任何诺曼公爵所能做到的。在一个能干的国王领导下——哈罗德绝对是这样的国王——潜在可召集的军队可能达到数万人。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们有该国各个领主所承担的军事义务的记录。因此，作为一个领地的领主，一个赛恩（Thine），就必须承担服兵役的义务。引用11世纪早期一篇关于此的文献：“为自由民配备武器，在海岸线上站岗放哨，并保卫自己的领主。”现在，那个领主可能是国王，但也同样可能不是，
these seem to date back to the time of Alfred, who had raised troops, paid troops to serve kind of as his bodyguard. The great earls of the kingdom, they have their house carls as well. And these are probably the most formidable infantry in Northern Europe. Perhaps one difference though between the house carls and their Norman equivalent is that England has been turbulent and there has been feuding between the different earls and stuff, but life in England is surely relatively peaceful compared with the very competitive arena of Northern and Central France and its environs.
比如某个伯爵之类的。是的。国王并不拥有所有的土地。有些伯爵拥有自己的土地。因此有许多赛恩对——我不知道——吉斯（Gytha）或莫克尔（Morcar）或其他人负有义务。而这些领主，他们的赛恩，许多比较富有的自由民，也就是所谓的“查尔”（charls）——你知道，这些人受到的武装保护完全不亚于诺曼骑士。他们熟练使用剑、长矛、斧头。他们甚至拥有马匹。除了这些可以按需召集的士兵，国王还有拿薪水的职业部队。所以，我想这相当于君士坦丁堡保卫皇帝的瓦兰吉卫队。这些就是“豪斯卡尔”（Housecarls），这是一个著名的名字。我的意思是，任何了解黑斯廷斯战役的人都知道豪斯卡尔。而且，
So might it be the case that even the best trained housecarl, their skills have not been as it were honed in competition as much as those of their Norman equivalent. I mean I think there are very particular reasons why the Normans are menacing in a way that the English aren't that we'll come to in due course. I mean they're not always fighting in Brittany and in Maine and all these kinds of places. But Harold has been fighting against say against the Welsh. Right.
这些似乎可以追溯到阿尔弗雷德时期，他曾招募士兵、支付薪水作为自己的近身卫队。王国的大伯爵们也有他们的豪斯卡尔。这些可能是北欧最可怕的步兵。不过，豪斯卡尔与诺曼同类军队之间也许存在一个区别，那就是英格兰历经动荡，不同的伯爵之间有过内部仇杀，但与竞争异常激烈的北部和中部法国及其周边地区相比，英格兰的生活肯定相对和平。
I mean Harold is a very practiced and experienced warrior. And he commands troops who have done a lot of fighting. So these are very, very formidable forces. Do you know what's happened, Tom? What's happened is that once again in the rest of history, we've forgotten about the Welsh. I haven't forgotten about the Welsh. I'd forgotten about them though.
因此，会不会出现这样的情况：即便是训练最好的豪斯卡尔，他们的技能也没有像诺曼同行那样在竞争中得到同等程度的打磨？我的意思是，我认为诺曼人具有一种英格兰人所没有的威慑力，这有着非常特殊的原因，我们稍后会讲到。我的意思是，他们并不总是在布列塔尼、曼恩以及所有这些地方打仗。但哈罗德一直在打仗，比如说对抗威尔士人。没错。
And that's sad. I feel bad now. I think that it does not pay to underestimate the enormous reserves of really quite skilled manpower that Harold can command. And also of course, he has the right in the time of national emergency, which 1066 patently is,
我的意思是，哈罗德是一位非常老练和经验丰富的勇士。他统帅着打过很多仗的军队。因此，这些是非常非常强大的军队。你知道发生了什么吗，汤姆？发生的事情是，在《历史的剩余》中，我们再一次把威尔士人给忘啦。我可没有忘记威尔士人。不过我刚才确实把他们给忘了。
to essentially summon every able-bodied freeman in England. And that is about 90% of the population. So 10% of slaves, 90% of free. And, you know, the kind of the lower orders are not well armed, but they can do sentry duty, garrison duty, whatever. They can wave a pitchfork. That kind of thing. And I think that these troops would feel a sense of duty as well as of obligation.
这真让人难过。我现在觉得有点内疚。我认为，低估哈罗德能够调集的、技能相当熟练的庞大兵源储备是极其愚蠢的。而且当然，在国家紧急状态时期——1066年显然就是这样的时期——他有权
So one of the great, the famous old English poems about the Battle of Malden, which we talked about in one of our first episodes, Earl Britnorth standing against the Viking invaders. And he pledges himself to the defense of what he calls folk and folden, his people and his native soil. And we're told by an English chronicler writing in the early 12th century that Harold had drawn on these sentiments, that he had called his people to exert themselves by land and sea for the defense of their country. So maybe kind of Churchillian rhetoric is being employed by Harold. Do you know what it is, Tom?
基本上召集英格兰每一个身强力壮的自由民。这大约占总人口的90%。其中10%是奴隶，90%是自由民。而且，你知道，底层民众虽然武装不太好，但他们可以担任哨兵、驻守防务，随便挥舞一下草叉。诸如此类。而且我认为这些士兵不仅有义务感，还会有一种责任感。
It's now is the hour. Riders of Rohan, oaths you have taken now fulfill them all to Lord and land. That's that's basically what this is. And William of Poitiers, Williams chaplain would agree. He says the English are absolutely motivated by patriotism. Yeah. And just to quote Michael Lawson, who wrote the definitive book on the Battle of Hastings itself, an absolutely, I mean, amazingly detailed,
所以，关于莫尔登战役的一首伟大而著名的古英语诗歌——我们在第一集节目中讨论过，伯爵布里特诺斯（Britnoth）抵抗维京侵略者。他发誓要保卫他所谓的“人民与土地”（folk and folden），即他的人民和他的故土。一位12世纪初的英国编年史家告诉我们，哈罗德正是利用了这些情感，他号召他的人民在陆地和海上为了保卫祖国而奋起抗争。所以哈罗德也许正在采用某种丘吉尔式的修辞。你知道这是什么吗，汤姆？
subtle treatment of all the sources and the evidence. Yeah. I mean, it's a passage that really struck me when I read it. The more that becomes known about the ways in which English armies assembled and fought in this period, the more it may become apparent that it saw the mobilization of the country and its resources for war to an extent that was not to be repeated until the total wars of the 20th century. Tom, do you know what that reveals?
现在就是时刻。罗汉的骑士们，你们许下的誓言，现在去对领主和土地全部履行吧。这——这基本上就是这个意思。而威廉的随身神父普瓦捷的威廉也会同意这一点。他说英格兰人绝对是出于爱国主义的动机。是的。只需引用迈克尔·劳森（Michael Lawson）的话，他写了关于黑斯廷斯战役本身最权威的书籍，绝对——我的意思是，极其详尽、
Michael Lawson has never heard of the Napoleonic Wars. Well, I was thinking that, but the militia in the Napoleonic Wars, I mean, it's pretty minor. The Napoleonic Wars is a massive total war. It's a total mobilization of English society, British society. He's talking about the manpower. All right. I'm just being mean to Michael Lawson for no reason.
微妙地处理了所有的资料和证据。是的。我的意思是，当我读到这一段时，它真的触动了我。对英格兰军队在这时期的集结和作战方式了解得越多，就越能明显看出，它见证了该国及其战争资源的动员，其程度直到20世纪的总力战之前都未曾再次出现。汤姆，你知道这说明了什么吗？
I mean, I did kind of ponder, you know, what would Pitt say about that? What would Nelson say of that, Tom? Unbelievable scenes. But the Navy, I mean, the Navy is really where England does its fighting the Napoleonic Wars. Yeah. Anyway, so, so essentially it would be foolish to underestimate the resources that Harold can command and William does not underestimate them. And so it is that far from rushing into an attack on England, he prepares for it
迈克尔·劳森从来没有听说过拿破仑战争。嗯，我当时也是这么想的，但拿破仑战争中的民兵，我的意思是，相当微不足道。拿破仑战争是一场大规模的总力战。那是英国社会、英国社会的全面总动员。他在谈论的是人力。好吧。我只是无缘无故地对迈克尔·劳森刻薄一下。
with a kind of remorseless care and, and, and attention to detail. So he, he needs to organize quite a lot before he can have a hope of invading England. So most obviously he needs ships and these are not just to transport his army, but to guard against the English fleet. And the Normans who were hostile to William's plans had explicitly cited a dread of English naval superiority. And they say of Harold for he had a numerous fleet and seaman expert in nautical matters. That's William of Poitiers there. The fleet is presumably not built entirely from scratch. Although if you look at the Bay of Tapestry, it seems to suggest as much, but it was clearly a huge effort. And so you would imagine all the way
我的意思是，我确实仔细琢磨过——皮特会对这个怎么看？尼尔森会对这个怎么看，汤姆？难以置信的场景。但海军，我的意思是，海军确实是英格兰在拿破仑战争中进行战斗的地方。是的。不管怎样，所以，所以基本上，低估哈罗德能够调集的资源将是愚蠢的，而威廉也没有低估它们。因此，他绝不是仓促地对英格兰发动进攻，而是进行了
through the summer, the dockyards of Normandy are echoing to the sound of hammer blows. This is like adventures in time. It's unbelievable. It's great prose, Tom. And then of course he needs men and William is not like Harold. He has to recruit essentially an ad hoc force. He doesn't have a military apparatus that he can just click his fingers and it all leaps
一种冷酷无情、一丝不苟的精心准备。所以，在他有希望入侵英格兰之前，他需要组织相当多的事情。最显而易见的是，他需要船只，这些不仅是为了运送他的军队，也是为了防范英国舰队。那些敌视威廉计划的诺曼人曾明确指出，他们对英国的海军优势充满了恐惧。他们谈到哈罗德时说：“因为他拥有庞大的舰队和精通航海事务的海员。”那是普瓦捷的威廉说的。这支舰队大概不是完全从头开始建造的——尽管如果你看巴约挂毯，似乎暗示了这一点——但这显然是一项巨大的工程。所以你可以想象，整个
into being. These are men fighting not for love of land and patriotism, Tom. They're fighting for money and greed. Oh, they're fighting for love of land. It's just other people's land. Yeah. And there are lots of people in France who are very interested in getting a bit of England.
夏天，诺曼底的造船厂里到处回荡着锤击的声音。这就像是时间的冒险。这太难以置信了。写得真好，汤姆。然后，当然，他需要人手，而威廉不像哈罗德。他必须组建一支基本上是特设的军队。他没有那种只要打个响指就能瞬间集结起来的军事装置。这些人打仗不是为了对土地的热爱和爱国主义，汤姆。他们是为了金钱和贪婪而战。哦，他们是为了对土地的热爱而战。只不过是别人的土地罢了。是的。法国有很多人对分一杯英格兰的羹非常感兴趣。
So William of Pratier lists men who come from the Royal heartlands of France. So Paris and Orléans from Maine, from Brittany, from Aquitaine. And when on the Beo tapestry, you know, there are those kind of Latin stitching describing what's going on and it shows William's army, he describes it not as an army of Normans, but a Frankie, a Franks, a French. And the fact that William is able to recruit so many people from so many different parts of France beyond his dukedom, I think is tribute not just to the greed and avarice of a Frenchman for English wealth and land, but also to William's fame as a warrior.
因此，普瓦捷的威廉列举了来自法国王室核心领地的人员：巴黎、奥尔良、曼恩、布列塔尼、阿基坦。当在巴约挂毯上——你知道，上面有那些描述正在发生的事情的拉丁刺绣，展示了威廉的军队时，他把这支军队不描述为诺曼人的军队，而是“法兰基”（Franki），即法兰克人、法国人。威廉能够从他的公国之外的法国各个不同地区招募到这么多人，我认为这不仅归功于法国人对英格兰财富和土地的贪婪与唯利是图，也归功于威廉作为一名勇士的声誉。
I mean, it's a tremendous tribute to his renown and charisma. And then on top of that, of course, William is a very, very able strategic planner. And he knows that if you are going to recruit large numbers of men, loads of whom are going to be bringing horses, the huge challenge is to keep them supplied while you're waiting to sail. And there's a famous essay by Bernard Bachrach. So not related to Burke, which demonstrated the challenge of stabling horses for one month. So he supposes that there were two to 3000 horses. And he says that this would have generated 700,000 gallons of urine, five million pounds of dung, and it would have taken 5,000 cart loads to remove.
我的意思是，这是对他声望和个人魅力的巨大赞誉。除此之外，当然，威廉是一位非常、非常出色的战略规划者。他知道，如果你要招募大量的人，其中很多人都会带着马匹，那么巨大的挑战就是在等待航行的同时保持对他们的补给。有一篇伯纳德·巴克拉赫（Bernard Bachrach）的著名文章——与伯克无关——它论证了将马匹拴养一个月的挑战。因此他假设有两到三千匹马，他说这会产生70万加仑的尿液，500万磅的粪便，并且需要5000辆大车才能运走。
And it has to be said that clearing d down kind of absolutely plays to William's strength. This is the kind of detail that he's all over. Yeah. He's not just about leading to battle charges. He's also about there once a natural meteor of a Frenchman. So even with all this, even with all his carts of dung and his and-faced greedy Frenchmen and whatnot. It's still a big, it's still a challenge, isn't it? He's got to basically get them across the channel.
必须得说，清理粪便这事绝对发挥了威廉的长处。这就是他擅长的细节。是的。他不单单是冲锋陷阵的领导者。他同时也是一个天生的法国大管家。所以，即便有了这一切，即便有了他那成车的粪便、满脸贪婪的法国人诸如此类的东西，这仍然是一个巨大的挑战，不是吗？他必须基本上把他们运过海峡。
He's got to land. He's got to win battles. He's got to get to London, all of that stuff. That I think is the key thing. The only way he can hope to win is to force a battle, which means effectively to gamble everything, his life, everything on a single decisive encounter. And the truth is, is that he's only fought one battle really before. And that was back in 1047 when he was about eight. He'd fought that pitch battle against
他必须登陆。他必须赢得战斗。他必须到达伦敦，所有这些事情。我认为这才是关键所在。他想要取胜的唯一希望就是迫使对方进行一场会战，这意味着实际上是要把一切——他的生命、一切——都押在一次决定性的遭遇战上。而事实是，他在此之前其实只打过一次真正的会战。那还是在1047年，当时他大约八岁。他与
the rebels against his rule. And so it's a huge gamble. And you might wonder, well, why would he take such a risk? I mean, he's, he's, he's built up so much in Normandy. Why would he risk it all? And I think it's because despite his respect for Harold and his military capabilities, William is confident that he will win. And that confidence is founded on various factors. The first is he is very aware of what he commands. He knows that Normandy is the most disciplined warrior society in Europe, and he knows that the Normans are capable of feats of conquest that is beyond the capacity of anybody else in Christendom. And he knows this because by 1066, those Normans who we talked about
反抗他统治的叛军打过那场阵地战。所以这是一场巨大的豪赌。你可能会纳闷，好吧，他为什么要冒这么大的险？我的意思是，他在诺曼底已经建立起如此庞大的基业，为什么要把它全押上？我想这是因为，尽管他对哈罗德及其军事能力表示尊重，但威廉坚信自己会赢。而这种信心建立在各种因素之上。首先，他非常清楚自己统帅的是什么。他知道诺曼底是欧洲纪律最严明的勇士社会，他知道诺曼人有能力完成基督教世界任何其他人所无法企及的征服壮举。他之所以知道这一点，是因为到了1066年，我们在上一系列节目中谈到的那些
in the previous series who traveled to Southern Italy and started attacking the Byzantines and the Muslims. They have crossed the Straits of Messina and embarked on the conquest of Sicily and it's going very, very well. So Norman adventurers, not even backed by Norman state power, have conquered most of southern Italy and are well on their way to conquering the whole of Sicily. William does appreciate, however, that this isn't just down to the qualities of Norman prowess, but also to factors that are common across France, but not England. And these are heavy cavalry, so people who the English are coming to call knights, the construction of castles, not just as defensive, but as offensive structures, and crossbows,
前往南意大利并开始攻击拜占庭人和穆斯林的诺曼人，已经跨越了墨西拿海峡，开始了对西西里的征服，并且进展得非常、非常顺利。因此，甚至没有得到诺曼国家权力支持的诺曼冒险家，已经征服了南意大利的大部分地区，并且正在征服整个西西里的道路上顺利前进。然而，威廉也意识到，这不仅归功于诺曼人自身的英勇品质，还归功于法国各地普遍存在但英格兰没有的因素。这些因素包括重骑兵——英格兰人开始称之为骑士的人，城堡的建造——不仅作为防御结构，也作为进攻结构，以及弩，
which are kind of new innovation that the English haven't really caught on to. And if the Byzantines and the Muslims in southern Italy and Sicily have, you know, they have no idea what's hitting them when the Normans fight them, then the likelihood is that neither will be English. So to quote a wonderful book, Predatory Kinship, the creation of Norman power by the great scholar Eleanor Searle. She wrote, the Anglo-Saxons lauded it from wooden halls and did not fight in sophisticated cavalry units, nor were they organized primarily for warfare as were William's magnates after their long testing and occupying and holding the land of enemies. England lay open without
这是一种英格兰人还没有真正掌握的新创新。如果南意大利和西西里的拜占庭人和穆斯林在遭到诺曼人攻击时完全不知道是怎么回事，那么英国人很可能也不会知道。因此，引用伟大的学者埃莉诺·塞尔（Eleanor Searle）的一本精彩著作《掠夺性亲属关系：诺曼权力的建立》中的话说。她写道：“盎格鲁-撒克逊人在木质大厅里夸夸其谈，并不在精密的骑兵单位中作战，也没有像威廉的贵族那样，在长期考验、占领和守卫敌人土地的过程中，将自己组织成主要为战争服务的力量。英格兰在
the new technology of warfare. So that's what you were saying that even though Harold and his house girls have been fighting fighting the mass of people in England are not organized for warfare in the way that the Normans are. She like me has forgotten about the Welsh. Anyway, obviously this is now Tom Holland bingo. Yeah, right. Because not only is there military technology that puts the Normans ahead, but dare I say there's also spiritual technology or at least a sort of ideological technology.
新型战争科技面前毫无防备。”所以这就是你刚才所说的，尽管哈罗德和他的豪斯卡尔一直在打仗，但英格兰的广大民众并没有像诺曼人那样为了战争而组织起来。她和我一样把威尔士人给忘了。无论如何，这显然现在成了汤姆·霍尔丁的“宾果游戏”（Tom Holland bingo）。是的，没错。因为不仅有让诺曼人领先的军事技术，而且我敢说，还有精神技术，或者至少是一种意识形态技术。
As you say, it's not just a military revolution that Latin Christendom is undergoing, it's a religious one as well. And it's a process that is called reformatio, a convulsive and deeply contested attempt to remake Christian society by cleansing and purifying it. And what that means in practice is a conviction on the part of leading figures in the Roman church that the church should free itself not just from sin but from the grubby fingerprints of sinners, which in effect means kings and emperors. And in the conviction that this is what God wants, they are pushing through a program of reform and to do this, effectively, they are a kind of cadre of revolutionaries who
正如你所说，拉丁基督教世界正在经历的不仅是一场军事革命，也是一场宗教革命。这个过程被称为“革新”（reformatio），是一场通过清洗和净化基督教社会来对其进行重塑的、痉挛性的且充满激烈争议的尝试。在实践中，这意味着罗马教会领导层坚信，教会不仅应该摆脱罪恶，还应该摆脱罪人油腻的手印，这实际上意味着国王和皇帝。在坚信这就是上帝旨意的情况下，他们正在推行一项改革计划；为了做到这一点，他们实际上是一支
have seized control of the commanding heights of the Roman church. And by 1066, the most formidable of these revolutionaries, the most influential, isn't the Pope, but an archdeacon by the name of Hildebrand and there is lines that are said of him that is very popular by the 1060s that if you would thrive at Rome say this at the top of your voice more than the Pope I obey the Lord of the Pope so that is Hildebrand and actually within seven years Hildebrand will become Pope and he will take the name of Gregory the seventh and he will take on the emperor himself and convulse the whole of
夺取了罗马教会指挥高地的革命者干部队伍。到了1066年，这些革命者中最强大、最有影响力的不是教皇，而是一位名叫希尔德布兰德（Hildebrand）的副主教。当时流传着一句关于他的、在11世纪60年代非常受欢迎的话：“如果你想在罗马飞黄腾达，那就大声说出这句话：‘比起教皇，我更服从上帝；比起教皇，我更服从领主’。”这就是希尔德布兰德。事实上，在七年之内，希尔德布兰德将成为教皇，他将采用格里高利七世（Gregory the VII）这个名字，他将向皇帝本人发起挑战并震撼整个
Europe but already in the 1060s you have a sense of this great earthquake that is to come and there is immense enthusiasm in France for this spirit of reform and the Normans especially are Absolutely signed up to it and they're very much Hildebrand's kind of people. They're very devout They're very effective at toppling people that Hildebrand's kind of people. They're very devout. They're very effective at toppling people that Hildebrand doesn't like. The Normans in Italy have basically become the sword of the papal reformers. So these revolutionaries, obviously they need men in mail with horses and spears and the Normans are there and it's absolutely brilliant. And so in 1063, Hildebrand had got the Pope Alexander to send Roger, count Roger de Hauteville, the guy who will lead the conquest of Sicily, to send him a papal banner.
欧洲，但早在1060年代，你就能感受到这场即将到来的巨大地震。法国对这种改革精神抱有极大的热情，诺曼人尤其对此绝对支持，他们非常符合希尔德布兰德喜欢的那种人。他们非常虔诚，在推翻希尔德布兰德不喜欢的人方面非常有效率。意大利的诺曼人基本上已经成为了教皇改革派的利剑。所以这些革命者，显然他们需要身穿锁子甲、骑着马、拿着长矛的人，而诺曼人就在那里，这简直太棒了。因此在1063年，希尔德布兰德让教皇亚历山大派遣罗杰——负责领导征服西西里的德·高特维尔家族的罗杰伯爵——给他一面教皇旗帜。
And this effectively is sanctifying his invasion of Sicily, ruled by the Muslims as a holy war. And they have also given a blessing to Normans who are fighting the Muslims in Spain. So you have there the sense that something very novel and radical, the idea that armed warfare can be blessed by the church is starting to coalesce as an idea. And the problem about this for the English is that they are very much not Hildebrand's kind of people. Yeah.
这实际上是将他对由穆斯林统治的西西里的入侵圣化为一场圣战。他们还向在西班牙与穆斯林作战的诺曼人给予了祝福。因此，你在这里感受到了一种非常新颖和激进的东西：武装战争可以得到教会祝福的想法，正开始作为一个理念凝聚成型。而这对英国人来说的问题在于，他们非常不符合希尔德布兰德喜欢的那种人。是的。
They are now ruled by a king who has broken an oath sworn on the bones of saints. You don't care about this. No. But Hildebrand absolutely does. The more I hear about this Hildebrand, the less I like him. He's a man who plunges England into 500 dark years only reversed in the 1530s. I think it's fair to say Tom. That is as may be and to be discussed.
他们现在由一位打破了在圣徒遗骨上所发誓言的国王统治。你不在乎这个。不。但希尔德布兰德绝对在乎。我听到的关于这个希尔德布兰德的越多，我就越不喜欢他。他是一个把英格兰带入500年黑暗时代的人，直到1530年代才得以扭转，我认为这样说很公平，汤姆。情况可能确实如此，有待探讨。
There is also a further problem with the English church, which is that Stigand, the Archbishop of Canterbury, he is the embodiment of everything the reformers hate. So as well as being Archbishop of Canterbury, he's also the Bishop of Winchester. He's venal. He's avaricious. He's cynical. Yeah, he's. He's venal. He's avaricious. He's cynical. Yeah, he's great.
英国教会还有一个进一步的问题，那就是坎特伯雷大主教斯蒂甘德（Stigand）。他是改革派痛恨的一切事物的化身。除了担任坎特伯雷大主教，他还是温彻斯特主教。他贪财。他贪婪。他玩世不恭。是的，他——他贪财。他贪婪。他玩世不恭。是的，他棒极了。
I love Stigand. The reformers in Rome keep excommunicating him and Stigand keeps snapping his fingers at this and say, well, say what? Who cares about a load of excommunications and saints bones? Come on. And he's so toxic that Harold has actually almost certainly refused to be crowned by him because he doesn't want William to take advantage of this, although the Normans will. I mean, they will say that he'd been crowned by Stigand, so he seems to have been crowned by Eldred instead. And all of this means that when
我喜欢斯蒂甘德。罗马的改革派不断将他绝罚，而斯蒂甘德则不断对此不屑一顾，说道：“好吧，说什么呢？谁在乎一堆绝罚和圣徒遗骨啊？来吧。”而且他是如此令人反感，以至于哈罗德几乎可以肯定拒绝由他加冕，因为他不想让威廉利用这一点——尽管诺曼人还是会利用这一点。我的意思是，他们会说他是被斯蒂甘德加冕的，所以他似乎是由埃尔德雷德（Eldred）加冕的。所有这一切意味着，当
William's ambassadors travel to Rome in the summer of 1066 to request a papal blessing for the invasion, Hildebrand behind the scenes is busy pulling strings to ensure that that is exactly what the Normans get. Like a corrupt and cruel spider. Or like a man determined to purge the Christian people of sin. Dominic, I mean, it depends on your perspective. Where's he now? I know we're good, I'll tell you.
威廉的使节在1066年夏天前往罗马请求为入侵获得教皇的祝福时，幕后的希尔德布兰德正忙着牵线搭桥，以确保诺曼人得到的正是这个。就像一只腐败而残酷的蜘蛛。或者像一个决心清除基督教人民罪恶的人。多米尼克，我的意思是，这取决于你的视角。他现在在哪儿？我知道我们很好，我会告诉你的。
And the upshot is that William is given the standard of St Peter the Apostle and it's been blessed by the Pope himself. And it has to be said that this is massively controversial across Europe, but also in Rome itself. To equate the English with infidels and to sanction the overthrow of an anointed king is a massive, massive deal. And Hildebrand himself acknowledges this. He writes to William, there are many among my brothers who reviled me for this judgment and charged me with laboring to bring about a terrible sacrifice of human lives. So that would be your take, I guess. But Hildebrandt's own conscience is clear because he thinks that a reformed, cleansed, purified England
其结果是，威廉获赠了由教皇本人祝福的使徒圣彼得的战旗。必须得说，这在整个欧洲以及罗马本身都引起了巨大的争议。将英国人等同于异教徒并批准推翻一位受膏的国王，这是一件非常、非常重大的事。希尔德布兰德本人也承认这一点。他写信给威廉：“我的兄弟中有许多人因这一裁决而责骂我，指责我费尽心机带来了一场可怕的人类生命牺牲。”所以我想这会是你的看法。但希尔德布兰德自己的良心是清白的，因为他认为一个经过改革、清洗、净化的英格兰
is a prize well worth fighting for. He sees it as a bog of sin that needs to be drained. And if William can affect this, then William will not only have served the cause of the reformers in Rome, but also of the sin steeped English themselves. Yes. Hildebrand is awake to sin and the English is sleeping. And obviously this is great news for William who is unbelievably ruthless, but also unbelievably pious. And it's the combination of the two that throughout this period, so terrifying and effective.
是一个非常值得为之战斗的奖品。他将其视为一个需要排干的罪恶沼泽。如果威廉能够实现这一点，那么威廉不仅服务了罗马改革派的事业，也服务了深陷罪恶的英国人自身。是的。希尔德布兰德对罪恶保持着清醒，而英国人却在沉睡。显然，这对于威廉来说是个好消息，他不仅冷酷无情到令人难以置信，而且虔诚到令人难以置信。正是这两者的结合，使得这一时期的他如此可怕且高效。
He is, he's going to be killing an anointed King, Morton Holland Bingo, and killing an anointed King is a big deal. But not maybe if this King is steeped in sin. Is that basically the claim? Well, he's going to put it to the test, isn't he? Because God is going to decide. Yeah. And it is a massive high stakes for William. It's not just about will he die in battle if he's defeated, but where will his soul go? Because as you say, to aspire to kill an anointed King, and then of course, in due course, William wants to become king and be anointed himself. I mean, if God is not on his side, then that
他将要杀死一位受膏的国王——汤姆·霍尔丁的“宾果游戏”——杀死一位受膏的国王是一件大事。但如果这位国王深陷罪恶，也许就不是了？这基本上是他的说辞吗？嗯，他要对此进行检验，不是吗？因为上帝会做出裁决。是的。这对威廉来说是一场高风险的巨大赌博。这不仅仅关乎他如果在战败中是否会死在战场上，还关乎他的灵魂将去往何方；因为正如你所说，企图杀死一位受膏的国王，然后当然，在适当的时候，威廉想要成为国王并接受自己的受膏——我的意思是，如果上帝不在他这一边，那么这就是一件
is a fateful thing to be planning. You could burst on your deathbed. That could happen to you. And let's see if that happens to William. And I think that the shadow of anxiety about this must have grown over William over the summer because throughout August and then into September, the winds are against him and he keeps praying, you know, let the winds turn, give us a favorable wind to get us to England, but they don't. And in England where Harold's levies are stationed waiting for this invasion and it doesn't come. By early September, provisions are running out. It's half his time and Harold must be thinking, well, I don't think he's going to come this year. I mean, it's too late. I don't think he's going to risk it crossing the channel
充满宿命色彩的计划。你可能会在临终前暴毙。这种事可能会发生在你身上。让我们看看这会不会发生在威廉身上。我认为，对这一点的焦虑阴影在整个夏天一定一直在威廉心中滋长，因为整个8月乃至9月，风向都对不利他，他不断祈祷，“让风向转变吧，给我们一阵顺风把我们送到英格兰”，但风就是不转。而在英格兰，哈罗德的民兵驻扎在那里等待这场入侵，但入侵却没有发生。到了9月初，给养开始耗尽。这已经是他的极限了，哈罗德一定在想，嗯，我想他今年不会来了。我的意思是，太晚了。我想他不会在这个季节的这个时候冒险横渡海峡了。
this late in the season. And so on the 8th of September, Harold decides to gamble that William will not be coming and he sends his men home. And he also sends his fleet to London, so from the South Coast. And as it is sailing up the channel, there is a terrible storm and the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle reports many perished before they reached London. So that is a blow. England's naval defenses are not what they might have been had that storm not blown. However, Dominic, this is not the worst news to greet Harold because when he arrived from the south coast in London, he is informed that what he had
因此在9月8日，哈罗德决定赌威廉不会来，他把士兵们遣散回家了。他还把舰队从南海岸派往伦敦。正当舰队沿海峡航行时，一场可怕的风暴袭来，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》报道说，许多人在到达伦敦之前就丧生了。所以这是一个打击。如果没有那场风暴，英格兰的海军防御本可能会更强。然而，多米尼克，这并不是迎接哈罗德的最坏消息，因为当他从南海岸抵达伦敦时，他被告知，他原本认为在这个季节的这个时候不会发生的事情发生了——英格兰遭到入侵了。
thought would not happen this late in the season has happened, that England has been invaded. It is not, however, a Norman invasion and it has not happened on the South Coast. Instead, it has happened in the North. The Great War fleet has sailed into the Humber. Tostig is back and with him your hero Harold Hardrada. Oh my word Harold Hardrada is back unbelievable scenes what a bum shell. Do you know I'm so excited that if I was a member of the Rest His History Club I'd listen to the next episode right away to see what happens when Harold Hardrada lands what's Harold Gobinson gonna do? Well Well, I know amazing stuff, heart stopping drama. And if I wasn't a member of the Rest is History Club, I would head immediately to the restish history.com because I would be a gog with excitement to find out what happens next
然而，这不是诺曼人的入侵，也没有发生在南海岸。相反，它发生在北方。庞大的主力战舰队已经驶入亨伯河。托斯蒂格回来了，和他一起来的还有你的英雄哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）。哦，天哪，哈拉尔·哈德拉达回来了，难以置信的场景，多么震撼的重磅炸弹。你知道吗，我太兴奋了，如果我是《历史的剩余》俱乐部的会员，我会马上听下一集，看看哈拉尔·哈德拉达登陆时会发生什么，哈罗德·戈德温森（Harold Godwinson）打算怎么做？嗯——嗯，我知道，太惊人了，扣人心弦的戏剧性。如果我不是《历史的剩余》俱乐部的会员，我会立刻前往 theresaisthehistory.com，因为我会激动得合不拢嘴，想要知道接下来会发生什么
in this extraordinary epic story of 1066. So Tom, that was that was so exciting. I just can't wait for the next episode and on that bombshell. Yeah. Goodbye. Bye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在这个关于1066年的非凡史诗故事中。所以，汤姆，那真是太令人兴奋了。我简直等不及下一集了，带着这颗重磅炸弹。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。